this week on quadriga re-importing
terror big threat for europe thousands
of foreign jihadists many of them from
europe are fighting alongside is forces
in Syria and northern Iraq why do young
Europeans head off to fight in a
religious war and how do they become
radicalized intelligence services warned
that those who return from the
battlefield could pose a threat to
public safety in the EU how serious is
the threat of reappointed terrorists and
how should Europe react to this
perceived danger your host this week
Melinda Crane hello and welcome to
quadriga one of the men implemented in
the beheading of two American
journalists himself appears to be
potentially one of those foreign
jihadists how should the rest of the
world be responding that's what we want
to talk about today with three people
who've been following events in the
Middle East very closely it's a pleasure
to welcome Marta leaming he's the
opinion page editor of Berlin based
newspaper editor Spiegel and he has also
served as the papers Washington bureau
chief and as its foreign editor covering
the security issues transatlantic
relations and the Middle East
hamid abdul samad is with us again he's
a freelance writer and journalist who's
made a name for himself as a critic of
Islam the son of an Egyptian Sunni Imam
he moved to Germany at the age of 23 and
it's a pleasure to welcome RC melody
flowey senior fellow at the Berlin based
Institute for Media and communication
policy the paris-based political
scientist and documentary filmmaker has
published widely among other topics on
jihadis I'd like to ask all of you to
start out by assessing how grave this
threat really is and by the way when we
talk about Isis today I think we will
use the term Isis they themselves are
sometimes now calling themselves Islamic
state but let's perhaps stick with Isis
just for clarity's sake mata looming
what would you say has the beheading of
the two American journalists and the
threat or one British one American
and the threat to behead yet another
change the calculus here that's a good
question I don't know whether changed
the calculus I mean the threat was was
there before and the war was going on
some even genocides or even grave acts
of terrorism have been committed so it
just added to these horrors that have
been before I mean the beheadings are
are a signal against first of all the
president of united states because
either he looks weak not reacting or you
pull him in again into Iraq and Syria
and all this mess
like before and that didn't come out
very good for the United States or the
rest of the world in Europe so that's
that's the tool they are using right now
it's a terrible tool but but I think the
Christians they use eat sand and all
other people down in the region it's
happening to them every day things like
that
I'll see Mel - Larry the man responsible
for the beheadings or at least one of
the people mainly responsible has a very
strong British accent appears possibly
to be a British national how should the
rest of the world be responding to that
and would you say that that's an
indicator that we really are facing a
very serious threat in our own countries
in the West yeah you're asking a
two-fold question are we facing a threat
here so far the Islamic state in
quotation marks and was concentrating on
expanding territory and controlling
territory which is quite new for jihadi
movements I mean successfully holding
territory and so we're not going for
this global jihad
due to the American intervention all
this might shift very quickly in a sense
the threat is real as the Islamic state
in quotation marks again has a highest
number of foreign recruits which we have
seen so far for a jihadi movement the
total number of European I've had last
estimates yesterday is exceeding two of
two thousand and two thousand young
Europeans so obviously if
the leadership of Isis is deciding to
start of adventure text there's a huge
potential of sending some people back to
Europe and which which are totally able
and trained to do attacks let's hope
that most of them are known that the
European security service will be able
to filter people are coming back but we
cannot be sure how that up does summon
is somebody isn't the primary goal of
Isis at the moment a geographical and
political goal rather than exporting
jihad back to the West as perhaps say
al-qaeda wanted to do isn't there a very
different motivation that is leading
these men to go to Syria and Iraq to
fight in on the side of Isis both sides
belong together they I would like to
disagree with azim that they are not
planning to expand outside their
territories no they are planning to do
that on the long-term and that what
makes them attractive also for young
European radical Muslims who want to
join this group because it has a global
dimension this young guy who beheaded
the American journalist is expected to
be a British citizen of Egyptian origin
and this message sent by this scene to
young radical Muslims in Europe is a
very dangerous message and here why I
see a new dimension in this brutality
because he's becoming like a role model
in Europe I was weak I was nobody and
now I'm extremely strong I'm like God I
decide if somebody would die or I decide
if somebody will stay alive this gives
many young radical Muslims option for
behavior in their life who feel like
nobody in Europe and that's why I see
the global dimension let me continue a
little on on your first remark obviously
all kind of jihad has a global dimension
but then a lot of jihadis can make local
choice so Isis initially was really
concentrating on the local jihad I mean
liberating territories in liberating
again in quotation marks in Syria and
Iraq
then again the global dimension comes in
as a strategic shift in reaction to
American involvement in direction to
reap European involvement against the
ISIS threat and then again you made a
very valid remark about ultraviolence
that something really new in terms of
jihadi movement that we have European
executioner's murderers who serve as
model who serve as an as an example for
other Europeans and Isis is really
living through altra violence military
success and ultra violence attracts a
lot of European recruits which makes a
movement quite dangerous multi looming
initially some months back clearly
security services in the US were
downplaying the potential of Isis to be
a very serious threat I think at one
point President Obama said look they can
put on the uniforms of professional
athletes but that doesn't make them a
world-class team now we're hearing from
Prime Minister David Cameron in Britain
this is an extremely grave and deep
threat greater than to our security than
any we've ever known what changed
I'm not sure if it's a gravest chief
threat that we've ever known that but it
is really a great threat it's great
threat for people living there I mean we
we saw first off the first group that
was pointed at was Christians then the
he sees and then Sunni themselves who
were not as radical as these groups are
so if it started in Syria now spills
over to Iraq we have a number of states
look look - Jordan how stable will
Jordan be look to Lebanon how stable
libanon stay and supported by Iran
through Iraq through all these so so
there is a potentially very very in
stable a geographical area there
now which may even seems that the
national state seaman seems to be in
danger like I've been writing about the
end of sykes-picot the end of this
colonial artificial borders interesting
enough and that's really one of the main
declared objectives of Isis to say we
end sykes-picot will end this artificial
artificial colonial States and create
through our Caliphate that traditional
recreates traditional Sunni Heartland
and this makes it very very attractive
for many people so I know but a basic
question is I mean since sighs because
clearly it's artificial borders but I
would say that 90% of all borders in the
world are artificial and and set at one
time or another by by a certain outcome
of a war or something else and so on so
the the problem is people have to learn
to live in a not ethnical cleansed stage
I mean to go away from sighs Baku means
we need to have ethnically defined
States and the modern concept of state
is if you have too many Germany Germany
couldn't live with Germany reunited as
well if we talk first about us minority
and I'm not I'm not I'm not saying that
Isis aims are are appreciable we you
know but I mean there's a I mean like if
you look at some kind of Sunni Heartland
like for in Iraq and Syria Mosul was
traditionally much closer to Syrian
cities like Aleppo then to Baghdad and
vice versa
so obviously there is a desire of those
populations to reunite in some form so
which is exploited by Isis let me bring
it back again now to the question of the
foreign jihadists hem it up does some
mod I know that you were once a member
of the Muslim Brotherhood but now you
say it is an organization that is
absolutely fascist in nature describe
for us if you would please what is the
attraction for these young men you
touched upon it before what draws them
there and what might we do to draw them
back yeah those people are attracted to
imagine
very identity and that's exactly what
those groups no matter if it's the
Muslim Brotherhood the Salafist group or
Isis or al-qaeda they give them the
impression there is a global Islamic
identity which is not committed to their
national borders the national states
couldn't offer those young people a
stable identity so that they can feel
home then they feel weak they feel
insecure in their identity and they need
an imaginary identity that that they are
a part of a great project and that's how
these radical groups work the Muslim
Brotherhood is the mother of all
Islamist organizations who came later
that throats of site code was caught up
one of the thinkers of the Muslim
brothers are the things which are quoted
now that we tried everything else we
tried capitalism with right communism
with right nationalism and it didn't
work out and we couldn't establish
strong Islamic states why don't we go
back to our origin
why don't we establish a state just like
the Prophet did 1400 years ago and
that's exactly what Isis is doing it's
carrying the same flag the Prophet was
carrying it's leading the same Wars
wants to purify the Arab countries from
everything which is not Islamic and is
therefore becoming brutal against
minorities like Christians or ect or
others I can't let this end that way in
a sense we can throw the Muslim
Brotherhood which can be at times or
also write Aryan but they're also
political Islamic movement belonging or
closest Muslim Brazil which have quite a
sense of democracy or at least for in
terms of popular remote agency let you
know better participation so let's not
throw everybody into the same basket but
then again I agree the charm of of Isis
in sis jihadi organization is that their
sex their really sex and sex which carry
huge promise especially jihadi movements
have such really
salvation promises salvation miss which
makes it so attractive
join us and you'll go to paradise join
us become a suicide become a suicide a
terrorist and you have immediate access
to to paradise so the whole salvation
miss of those groups is a very very big
danger especially for Western use a lot
of a lot of increasingly and the Western
use who that is recued recruited there
has social problems sometimes has a
criminal background I mean recruitment
to salafism jihadism in prisons in
France and and increasingly so in
Germany and Great Britain is quite high
so they have this promise of paradise to
offer join us and we forget what you did
before and they go very high to
salvation this is one of the major
threats if you join us and will forgive
your sins and you have immediate access
to paradise but there go even beyond
that and that until until that al-qaeda
was using this strategy just they were
recruiting suicide bombers who will go
soon to paradise but Isis is also
offering a paradise on earth it's
offering success in this life come to us
you don't have to die but anyway yes you
have you have to have a win-win
situation you have a win-win situation
either you will win the war with us so
you will be financially and politically
successful in this life or you die then
you go to paradise apparently Martin
lemon ices is also offering quite a bit
of money the recruits who join Isis
apparently are promised quite good
salaries for their efforts and we are
told that there are a number of soldiers
who are trained in Germany in the German
armed forces who are actually now
heading to fight side-by-side with Isis
partly for financial reasons yes I mean
ok we have to look at we have two
different kind of groups we have the
cell in Hamburg responsible for 911 they
were mostly foreigners living mostly
isolated in Hamburg now we have the
jihadis they are coming they have German
passports most of them are born in
German or even Germans
of them are convert IDEs so basically
what motivates them none of us knows
maybe it's attraction of Islam maybe
it's money maybe they have their own
psychological problems nobody really
knows we have no study about what
motivates young jihad is to go there I
very much doubt it's from social social
classes we have we have rich people we
have poor people we have educated people
and uneducated people so very very
different the problem and the threat is
that they have our passports they speak
our language and if they come back they
have the experience of war they've seen
brutality they've seen blood they've
seen murder they're living side by side
in us now and hand over in Munich or in
a small town in Bavaria what do you
think yeah I mean you have thousands of
reintegrating programs for regular
soldiers in countries like the United
States Great Britain even in Germany
dealing with post-traumatic syndrome
treating with all the stress from war
times and even though you have these
programs you have psychological many
many problems like suicide rates like
like like going our noggins things like
that it is a huge problem now you have
young people with the experience of
brutal war in Syria coming back at home
this is calling a yes dad let's talk
right away about how to respond but
perhaps first take a brief look at what
we've seen of a response so far if you
remember when President Obama ordered
the airstrikes it was as a very limited
reaction he described it basically as a
means of preventing genocide against the
yeah cities and also of protecting
American diplomats in the Kurdish
regional capital Erbil has the threat
now altered to the point that the
response should be considerably
different thousands of refugees are
fleeing the is Amnesty International has
accused the jihadists of systematic
ethnic cleansing large numbers of year
CDs and other minorities have been
abducted and possibly murdered the list
of those missing grows longer each day
the is militants came and separated the
women and children from the men they
killed all the men and took all the
women and children to Tal Afar the Sunni
jihadists have vowed to kill everyone
they view as infidels and prove that
they simply execute many of the people
they abduct is mounting this is not some
foreign conflict thousands of miles from
home that we can hope to ignore the
ambition to create an extremist
Caliphate in the heart of Iraq and Syria
is a threat to our own security here in
the UK the European governments are now
increasing efforts to stop the flow of
jihadists from Europe to war zones in
the Middle East
we've all got to apply most of all we
need international cooperation in
particular with countries such as Turkey
but also within the European Union
running of innovation I see my
elderflower you were starting to say we
do know something about the motivations
for foreign jihadism what do they tell
you about how we in the West should be
responding to this problem is it in
essence a military issue or is it a
political issue a policing issue what's
the best response here it's both it's
everything to respond to jihadism you
need to have some give some society for
answers you have to give some social
answers and obviously there's also a
military response in terms of
radicalization I mean there have been
studies many studies about why people
would become jihadis but what all the
studies show that there is no single
determining factor why people become
jihadis I mean it's really multi fold
there are various reasons but one of
them in Europe is definitely for example
alienation from European society and to
search for meaning so and we have
studies and we have to give if we look
at the current situation in Syria and in
Iraq and military and the security
response but we also need to give
responses on the social level with
prevention programs all around Europe
with with D radicalizing programs all
around Europe I mean Germany's on the
forefront the Germans are quite good for
a couple of years as really investing
times and energy and money in civil
society and institutes in grassroot
initiatives and there's still a lot of
work to do in order to prevent
radicalization but it needs to be common
European approach and the huge debate in
European societies of how to prevent
this radicalization if we have for
instance very little cooperation on the
level of radicalization prevention while
we have more and more security
cooperation obviously in Europe but only
security cooperation is not the answer
I'm a doctor some are staying with that
question of prevention and policing we
saw Prime Minister Cameron
speaking there he's pushing hard for
much tougher measures now in Britain
even returning to something called
control orders that was a form of house
arrest for people who were thought to be
potential jihadists also talking about
taking away the passports of people who
either are returning from the Middle
East and might be potential jihadis or
for those who might want to go what do
you think about that is that not perhaps
undermining the very thing we believe we
stand for in the West no I think it's
trying to recorrect the mistakes that a
country like Great Britain did in the
past let's look at the guy who is
supposed to be the one who beheaded the
American journalist James Foley or the
two journalists now he is having
Egyptian origin his father came as
asylum seeker to Great Britain everybody
knew he is a fundamentalist but he was
granted asylum and a few years later he
joined al-qaeda and became one of the
most effectively Oh tennis idols from
one extreme to the other and and in the
name of tolerance Great Britain was
opening its arm for those people because
it thought they are persecuted in their
own country and we need to give them a
shelter but they didn't have a eye on
them and let them build up a
fundamentalistic infrastructure which is
the worst in Europe right now there are
certain provinces or certain suburbs in
London and some other cities that you as
a European can walk there because they
are controlled by Islamists and Islamic
rules are valid there and this young man
so now we have a case of homegrown
terrorism and imported terrorism and
that's what should be thought about when
we are thinking about solutions when
those people are coming back everybody
is saying like
they need psychologists and then they
need some therapies no they are
criminals they are terrorists they
should be dealt with as criminals in the
first place but then that doesn't mean
that the prevention shouldn't go forward
you have been talking about successful
prevention in Germany how do how do you
calculate that we have fertilizer Iran
is working did a good dragon attack but
when we see how many are the number of
Salafist is growing in Germany we have
400 or more fighters German fighters in
Syria and we have more people who are
sympathizing with them here it means
this kind of grassroots initiatives
until now they didn't show that it's
effective enough it didn't prove the
contrary but at least something is done
but coming back to Britain Britain had a
very particular approach I'm true enough
London was called for why Lord Lord
honest an as a lot of jihadis returning
in the 90s from Afghanistan could speak
freely could create networks among them
the father of the supposed be header of
the American journalist now after the
two bombings in 2005 Britain reversed
course and took extremely radical
measures to combat G Edison
most more extremes in all European
countries the legendre lawyers the
legendary the legendary British freedom
of speech went away they even punish
people for just possessing jihadi
propaganda I mean there which
radicalized people further in a sense
there was a famous case a case of a
young girl a young lady who wrote a poem
poem in the glory of bin Laden and got a
jail sentence for it so they push it
very far I fear taking more security
measures more repressive measures also
can create the inverse effect and
recognise people further so there needs
to be very very carefully sort of
balance between prevention repression
legislation frameworks so I'm there's
always a risk if you go too far you
recognize people further you elminate
from society Martin lemming way in here
on this if you would please Britain has
now raised its anti-terror warning to
the second-highest level should Germany
do the same it has nearly the same
number of nationalists fighting on the
side of Isis right now it's as far as I
can tell I mean all of the informations
are with the with the secret services
and place like this and they say no
right now and I have just my job as a
citizen is to believe them I have no
special informations about how huge
threat is I mean first of all it clearly
has to be said the biggest threat from
Isis right now coming from minorities in
the region themselves they're killing
them by thousands every day so we are
talking kind of a luxury threats that we
are in we are in a real threat that is
it's right now they've not committed any
kind of terrorism here first of all I
would say yes we have tools so we could
label ice as a terrorist organization we
have not done that yet we should do like
al-qaeda like like a news go hunt like
everything else so that even joining
them is a criminal act that if you
travel there to fight you are and I
agree with Hamid you are a criminal
you're doing criminal acts by coming
home meaning you you're going to jail if
you join them that means joining a
terrorist organization on me I don't
think there's any doubt that that Isis
is a terrorist organization about flows
of money what could be done to shrink
the flows of money to Isis we have heard
that business is one of the richest
terrorist organizations there has ever
been what can be done there that's the
whole discussion we have to we have to
have very open in the West because we we
didn't have right now I mean the Saudi
Arabia Qatar and all these states they
have the kind of a double gain some of
the more free some of the people are
condemning Isis saying even this is kind
of a threat but but in the countries
themselves and in finance flows and
everything else they are supporting its
supporters coming out of these states to
these organizations so that is a real
problem that we have with these
especially these two countries
golly you're shaking your head we're
told that people in Qatar and Saudi
Arabia two of the closest allies of the
West are very much part of the funding
stream that is obviously obviously like
I'm Qatar Saudi Arabia both businessman
funded a lot of jihadi movements and
historically the Saudis have done a lot
to curb it whether really successful
we don't know but I mean but the real
issue is especially in terms of Isis
they don't need Qatar in Saudi money
anymore just self financing and that's
where the real issue is Saudi Arabia is
so afraid from Isis they're really
controlling money flows there but they
control the oil fields they control even
flows of agricultural products a year
ago two years ago the Syrian opposition
figure was showing me a map of Syria
explaining those people will control in
the future that and that's where the
money comes from from really export
taxes from oil from even the huge
agricultural product so Isis doing very
well and self financing it as the state
as they declare and now they won't we
won't be able to limit their access to
money if we don't defeat the militarily
Oh Abdul Samad I'd like to come to the
military a question now I was in the
United States when the first beheading
was announced of the American journalist
and it certainly changed the tenor of
the discussion there we saw very very
strong criticism from conservatives for
example from the US senator and former
presidential contender John McCain who
said we need a much more robust military
response to this threat on the other
hand some are arguing for instance one
of the main New York Times editorial is
Tom Friedman saying all of this is
guaranteed to provoke a hasty military
response on our part that is exactly
what they're looking for and it would be
a huge mistake what do you say yeah what
should we do I mean those people are
criminals who are killing people who
want to have genocides they are
dismissing diseases and Christians from
their cities and villages
what should be the proper response if
you will do nothing their power will
increase and they will pose a much
greater threat in the future I think
this area they should not initiate area
I think they should not only bomb they
should also send ground troops to Syria
unto Iraq because the Kurds alone cannot
stop these growing armies which are very
vital and very dynamic and they are
gaining territory money and oil fields
day after day and we have been talking
about Great Britain that at the
beginning was too much tolerant and
easygoing in dealing with terrorism I'm
saying always a stitch in time saves
nine if we act in the right time then we
don't have to do a lot if the night
states had the right strategy in Iraq
after the war we wouldn't have been here
yet but under the pressure everybody was
saying the United State has to everybody
was criticizing United States for having
troops in Iraq okay
Bush did a great mistake we agree upon
that but those who have been pushing the
United States to leave Iraq what what
what are they having now Iraq itself is
pushing the United States today I'm not
slimming Western ground troops are
obviously not going to be going into
this conflict but there is a lot of
pressure for a wider military response
as I say possibly bombing Isis positions
within Syria that would take this to
quite a different level would it not is
there a military solution to this
conflict in an ideal world if you could
send for example ground troops to there
from America or even from from Arab
states why not from from Saudi Arabia
and Qatar if they are so declaring
themselves to be an enemy why don't they
fight that's one of the options and your
discussion at the moment on the
discussions I doubt that this is a
realistic option I doubt the most
realistic option right now is
containment so you have to arm the Kurds
in the north you have to look for
stability in Jordan you have Turkey on
the flank you have some
how to contain the ISIS with military
terms in just I mean of giving the right
weapons to the right people right now
your government decided the German
government decided this week to send
arms to the Kurds a rather unusual
decision in this country which tends to
stand back from involvement in military
conflicts how concerned are you that
that decision could provoke exactly the
kind of returning jihadism that we've
been talking about provoke some of those
German nationals in the conflict to come
back here with bomb vests on I'm not
afraid about that I did the jihadis who
are going to Iraq or Syria to fight that
they don't need extra motivations to
kill people in Germany so they will
always find an excuse if they want some
to be radical if they are here but
sending weapons is not the extra thing
that motivates them to be a real
terrorist I don't think that assume if
flowey would a military defeat let's say
there were stronger action perhaps by a
combination of Western forces together
with some from neighboring states and
the Kurdish forces strengthened if Isis
were to see serious defeats would that
likely provoke more jihadis to return
here could defeat be counterproductive
in other words no but if there's always
a risk if you have a defeated armies
that you have returning soldiers who
create havoc somewhere you know that's
its history of wars you know but there's
another very very important issues maybe
Isis isn't that militarily strong maybe
the symbolic defeats will also take away
a lot of recruitment then again there's
a there's a huge political huge
political agenda to follow in order to
defeat Isis we shouldn't forget that
Isis would have never taken a city was a
million have much more than a million
inhabitants like Mosul very important
historical certain without creating very
powerful local alliances local alliances
with huge Sunni tribes yoga local
Sciences with x-bar thirst pros atom
configurations and again most was a very
good example you know most was a
recruitment round since the Ottoman
Empire for Iraqi army officers the
traditional Iraqi military comes out of
Mosul so those people align themselves
with Isis for obvious political reasons
but those people if we inside them if
they find their place in Iraq in an now
shiite-dominated dominated Iraq might
also defect in a split second from Isis
we have seen this in 2006 when the
Americans won over huge Sunni tribes the
Sunni leaders from al-qaeda in
Mesopotamia which was the predecessor of
Isis and Isis what is now Isis nearly
collapsed totally in 2006 we might see
the same thing if we give political
incentives choose the Syrian and Iraqi
supporters and allies of Isis so that's
something we should never neglect one of
the reasons that we're in this mess you
mentioned before hamid abdul samad
mistakes that were made in the past one
of the reasons we're in this mess of
course is because of the Syrian civil
war the West held back for a very long
time from supporting the opposition to
Assad precisely because they were afraid
that they might wind up supporting
fundamentalist Islamists if they now go
to war against Isis the reverse occurs
they are potentially indirectly helping
Assad is that something we really want
to be doing no but it doesn't have to be
always that choice between pests and
cholera it looks like that it it looks
like that because we have been waiting
too much as the this Arab Spring started
it was carried out by mostly secular
young people who wanted change and as I
said already in 2011 that we need
intervention in Syria
I was the bad guy but but with this
mentality I said a stitch in time saves
nine because we will need a much greater
war later if we don't intervene now the
same thing happened in Libya the same
thing happened in Iraq before it was a
great mistake to let thing drift away
and that's we are exactly getting this
danger now we think we will give like
some weapons to the Kurds and we think
that will solve the problem and we'll be
in peace no that might delay the problem
until for some reasons maybe Isis will
take over the Kurdish area and take the
same weapons we get just like they took
muscle and take the same weapons that
the West sent to the Iraqi army before
and that's what makes them strong what
makes us so sure that this will not
happen and the motivation for the Kurds
what motivates them to fight fiercely
they want to have their own state but
Western governments are saying that they
don't want have a independent Kurdish
state why not why don't we open up also
this taboo topics we we all want a
Palestinian state but when it comes you
should raise the end of sykes-picot and
not leave it rises that's what you're
saying yes we can open all in fact Omata
leaming the German government officially
still says it doesn't want a separate
Kurdish state but when they armed
Kurdish Peshmerga they are also helping
to our members of the PKK and that is
their avowed aim have we in fact already
given up on some of the ideas of an
integrated secular Islam that our Middle
East that we say we're still clinging to
I think right now and maybe you're right
right now many people are giving up on
the idea to have a viable - nation-state
Syria and Iraq in the present borders
this is really really difficult and it
might take 10 20 or 30 years the the
most likely option is that you that you
have a kind of sacra
gated places there for special ethnic or
religious entities like Lebanon yeah
like they belong yes okay for a lot of
ethnic cleansing
okay there is recipe for that too and I
have a little bit to disagree with with
Amin because we had an intervention in
Libya and look to Libya right now I mean
we they they they killed Gaddafi and
look further it is a mess you didn't do
the job until they and it's okay then we
should have sent ground troops to Libya
that we have to send ground troops to
Syria to ground troops to Iraq how many
ground troops you think will we need to
do this is the world we are living in
and that's exactly because of lack of a
balance in the poor diet as you have
fighters on the one hand who are ready
to die for their cause who are brutal
and you have the Western civilization
that wants to do everything with the
hand gloves and without any loss this is
not possible in the north
supporting the secure secular opposition
in Syria against Assad against Russia
against Iran against Hezbollah
that is this is a very tough fight to do
to have are you ready until aiming just
mentioned Iran that's another of the
perverse side effects of this entire
conflict a CLD family the fact that if
we were to defeat Isis militarily and or
by other measures we would indirectly be
strengthening Iran
yeah but then Zeron Iran is already
strong enough in the region was all the
terminal going on
I mean what's long overdue and every
reasonable political analysts would say
so Iran should from for a long time have
been integrated in all the political
process in the diplomatic efforts about
Syria and about Iraq and factually there
will be integrated as lot of talk behind
the scenes
now I'm when we talk about this military
solution and and the end of sykes-picot
and not for my borders and they're huge
similarities between ex-yugoslavia
and the areas the areas struggle areas
of Syria Lebanon and and Iraq
ex-yugoslavia and all
the middle-eastern errors we were
speaking about we're just badly
decolonized from the Ottoman Empire
badly broken up so there's a real
historical parallel there and what we
see today next years now there might be
an example as well we have ethnic states
we had a horrible Wars not won several
Kosovo Bosnia Croatia and so on but
today we have the absence of war into
certain a reintegration so maybe this is
an example you know already let us
create the absence of war and then see
how these those ethnic groups can live
together and I'm not I'm very really I'm
not sure if three steps to that very
concrete what happens what people have
been for long fire I mean integrate even
Assad now and say ceasefire we talk to
you if if an immediate ceasefire in
Syria and then we take it from there the
same for Iraq the Sunni Sunni population
of Mosul we agree on autonomy in the
ceasefire and then we all talk Hamid
Aptus Ahmad briefly where it work it's
not enough it's not enough
those people are burning the country and
they are interested that the fire will
continue to go on
okay thank you our discussion on this
subject undoubtedly will continue to go
on in future programs I thank all of you
very much for being with us today and
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon
you